the Joe Rogan experience I mean I love
drink I mean I drink I mean I still I
joke about it like I love my sobriety
but like one and a half vicodin and
three beer was like the best I've ever
felt in my life
yeah and like a cigar what I went to
Baghdad I did like USO thing with Nate
bargatze
and we had like moobot Cubans and I had
some Vike like a vicodin I don't know if
he did I don't want to I don't think he
did but I'd like a vicodin we had a
couple beers and a cigarette Saddam
Hussein's palace in the moment I was
like this is the best I've ever felt did
you do stand-up over there yeah what is
it like doing stand-up for the troops
over there it was fun it was a mate it
was the most grateful audience they were
like so nice and kind and it was really
cool I mean some of it suck because
someone was like 2:00 in the afternoon
and there's like 12 guys it's [ __ ]
100 degrees they're holding rifles being
like what the [ __ ] is this
that was the show a couple of them yeah
some of them were like the ones in
Kuwait we're better because that was
like not a war zone
and you're on a base and I'd like a
hundred people but some of them were
like just in the middle of the 11
o'clock in the morning in the middle of
[ __ ] Baghdad Wow
it was pretty amazing like we got to fly
on these Black Hawks and we were in
Baghdad we went by the those cross
swords and stuff where the statue was
pulled down and [ __ ] what did you do
when you were in Sodom Hussein's palace
that became like an American base we
stayed there Wow yeah it's kind of a DIN
Sodom Hussein's palace yeah I don't
think I did I think Nate and I shared a
room and I asked he said no I would have
to I think I feel compelled I'd be like
bro you're gonna have to leave the room
I got a I got a goal I got to check
something off the list
it's it's a bizarre feeling cuz you know
we like it was like yeah we took over
and then just made this palace into him
face and there's like a driving range
you can like hit into like his prayer
pond or whatever whatever the [ __ ] it's
like a reflection pool you got a prayer
pond filled with golf balls yeah that's
hilarious and they sell Cubans and like
the lobby America yeah we're somewhere
we're we are [ __ ] slum yeah
but no it was amazing it was awesome one
time we were on the Black Hawk
helicopter and they shoot flares out for
whatever I can't remember why
on every flight but they didn't tell us
that so all of a sudden you just hear
like and you feel the heat and I thought
we were in a [ __ ] battle like I
almost [ __ ] my pit like it felt like you
know you don't have to [ __ ] and all of a
sudden you're like there's a [ __ ] I
could [ __ ] right now yeah it was that
feeling your body tries to evacuate
anything in there because it thinks it's
in danger yeah so like with spheal we
want to be able to run let's get on yeah
yeah when you get really nervous like
that that's that you immediately have to
piss and [ __ ] yeah I just took a huge
[ __ ] right before this show did you use
the little buttons on the toilet to
shoot water up your [ __ ]
it wasn't here I was afraid you'd beat
me up if I shouldn't so is that the
Starbucks
[Applause]